you ready to go yeah all right here we
are all right ladies and gentlemen you
know welcome back to your favorite
podcast you know the name which likes to
sing in Mike
that's fun you like that
[Music]
give me some obeys
[Music]
[Music]
anyway this thing is always here if you
want to grab it you just got to turn it
on sometimes people make a point they go
I need to sing that point
hey what let me tell you sometimes when
people say certain things it reminds me
of a song like speckly like somebody
would just say something something
hard-to-get she's playing huh that's why
I want you to grab the singing mic when
you feel like that knock over the
candles set us on fire from the hangover
a candle company who sent me these you
know every time I say his name on a
thing he like there's an Instagram post
up hey everybody sorry for the
interruption and I hope you're enjoying
the podcast if you want to see me live
listen I'm coming to a city near you
go to Eric Griffin calm to check out my
tour dates I know the web sites wonky
I'm sick of hearing about it but you can
still check out the tour dates as of
this podcast released my next date will
be out in the funny bone in Dayton Ohio
so make sure you come check me out and
if you want to see if I'm coming to a
city near you Eric Griffin calm for tour
dates please check that out I want to
come see you guys and thanks for
supporting me from with Griffin now to
get to some bidness I got an ad guys
haven't even been doing the podcast a
year and I got this great new sponsor
it's called my bookie let's do some
business y'all I love it now listen I'm
a super clipper fan I'm a super Raider
fan and sometimes you want to bet on the
game and I'm all about that and this is
what this site is all about so I wanna
so special thanks a lot of things go out
to my bookie for supporting riffing with
Griffin
my bookie has better bonuses and more
progress than any other sports book
period this year they're hosting the
first handicapping super contest first
place is guaranteed to win $100,000
and it's only cost $100 to enter visit
my bookie online and use the promo code
riffin to create your account to claim
the bonus I hope you enjoy the rest of
the podcast but anyways first of all
let's do this welcome to the podcast
very funny who I've known for so many
years the talented miss Angela Johnson
hello ok so you're here we did all that
good to see you I know let's get to it
you know why I thought of having you one
- Parker why is because I was on YouTube
and your video came up and it was like
10 years mm-hmm it was like I said oh my
god that was 10 years ago ray you know
and like the the things have changed
like the algorithms have change like
like I think I think you you know I
really think that you were the original
go viral I want to agree with you and
say at least out of comedy and stand-up
are sure and I'm not talking about
comedy in the sense of like a cat doing
something funny or a dog like whatever
like a stand-up comedian an actual
stand-up comedian I would agree with you
but I'm not gonna like go on record
saying that for a fact because I have
not done research on that nor do I care
to do research I don't know who cares I
do remember when this brand new thing
called YouTube came out and my video
went viral pretty much immediately yes
and I remember I remember the X I
remember like oh you're doing comedy she
was with the Raiders and other stuff and
everybody's like you know and but I
think that that was in the Golden Age of
and I know what you mean about the echo
but don't worry about it oh boy okay
just because we're excited now I hear it
a little bit - all by myself she tell
you nerds out there - keep sending
resumes - be my get res amazing oh
they're listening and they're going oh
he need help ya know cuz I say it I'll
be like oh man I'm doing this or
somebody you'll say something and
they'll be like yeah but it's it trust
me it's fine it's great you know if
somebody wants to intern though listen
we don't have any salary positions open
just yet but if you down for an
internship
exactly you learn
you know learn some is outs of Industry
about sound and everything but I think
back then YouTube was new but the thing
about YouTube also was they didn't
realize they weren't trying to
capitalize on it yet they weren't trying
to control it so it was like a wildfire
they could just go and that's what
happened with that you know so you know
you had this famous nail salon bit and
here's the thing about it is I remember
at the time you know like the haters
would hate you know you got a million
girls going when I first wrote that joke
here's the thing I started stand-up
comedy by taking a free joke writing
class in a church that's how I started
doing stand-up comedy I'm not even
joking it was Tuesday night the Oasis
church no crispy and that's my act today
I still okay so let me let's touch on
crusing after this point right here
so I took this free joke writing class
out of church and I remember it was
being taught by a comedian who I I came
and I said I have this nail salon
character that I do and I think I could
make that into a joke and she was like
Stan no nail salon jokes are so hacky
everybody has a nail salon joke I would
just steer clear from doing a nail salon
joke and I was like doesn't the way I do
so I'm just gonna try it anyways and
then thank God I did because it ended up
blowing up and it's funny because now
people will met not lately but I
remember I would get it for a while
people go Oh so-and-so's doing your nail
salon joke and I'm like no they're not
they're doing a nail salon joke because
many people go to nail salons like nail
salon jokes y'all I don't own them I
just do my own story of what I have
experienced and it just so happens that
a lot of people have experienced what I
have but see I don't again I'm not even
trying to touch on that part of it
because that has destinated here nor
there in terms of like who cares about
that
you know everybody it's like it's like
if somebody's talking about driving or
going to the DMV
I got spanked when I was a kid why we
all got same experiences what I'm really
referring to or talking about with you
is the fact that like that was like the
Golden Age of YouTube they just didn't
know what they had right and so then
here you put this thing like you say you
put it on the Internet here's the thing
oh you did I did not put it on YouTube
that's exactly what I'm saying that's so
I had no idea let me tell you somebody
has made a lot of money off of me
because it's not me
I I don't know if they were monetizing
back then but it's maybe how they are
well okay let me tell you what it is so
I got offered to do ten minutes at the
Ice House and this company who I'm not
gonna say their name because for certain
reasons but they said um come do your
ten minutes and we'll pay you twenty
five bucks and we're gonna record it and
this is before YouTube came out we're
gonna record it and it'll be comedy
clips people can download on their phone
like flip phones oh I remember
and they'll pay a dollar ninety nine for
some comedy clips that's what they're
about they're gonna charge people a
dollar ninety nine for comedy clips on a
flip phone
right so they come here's your twenty
five bucks we recorded your 10 minutes
great well then next thing you know this
brand new thing called YouTube comes out
so they go and they change and they take
all that content that was gonna be for
flip phones and they put it on YouTube
so they own that they own that material
not that material they own that video
footage and so that video footage went
viral and made lots of money so I signed
away that footage so whoever owns it
they're the ones that make money because
it's they own it oh those best what I
mean thank you yeah I'm grateful thank
you for putting it out there I
appreciate it also you're welcome for
all the millions of dollars you probably
have yeah it's crazy that's uh yeah so
it's like you know so now I don't know
if that kind of thing is possible
anymore just the way they have all these
algorithms and analytics right how they
decide who gets to see what like back
then it was just like you know it was
just like you share it you know it was
just being shared and if there's a
commercial on it then maybe you don't
watch it but like that's what it is now
back then there were no commercials oh I
know that's what I'm saying it's like
they really figured out what they
and so it's like but I always think back
to that when I saw that I was like man
it's to ten year anniversary they're
like do you count that as the thing that
sort of changed you're a comedy
tradition so freaking lutely absolutely
2007 was a year that changed my life let
me tell you what happened I had nothing
in my life at the time okay I I was an
extra on TV and then I lost that gig and
now I'm on unemployment I have no job I
have no agent I have no auditions no
opportunities nothing in my life saying
you're on the right track keep going and
a year prior I had films that thing at
the Ice House and so it's now January
2007 I have no money I'm considering
going back home because everything in my
life is like well you tried but it
didn't work out so now go back home at
home is in San Jose San Jose yeah so I
end up staying in LA and I stayed for
two reasons one because I felt like God
was not done with me yet like it was one
of those like even though my
circumstances were saying like you
failed I just felt like a gut-check in
my spirit and everybody what you call it
whatever you want your intuition your
God talking to you your higher self
knowledge whatever you want to call it I
had that gut check in my spirit that I
felt was God telling me I'm not done
with you yet like don't give up it's I
know it looks bad now but don't give up
that and my sister would send me gift
certificates to the grocery store so
that I could eat food she would send me
money I ran it's called family food
stamps yes yes I was on the family food
stamp program for a real long time and
and what happened was I ended up staying
and this video comes out from January to
February 2007 there's like 4 million
views on this video and I start getting
this is in my space days ok so I start
getting messages on MySpace from people
all over the world hey when are you
coming to perform in Australia New
Zealand the Philippines all over the
United States when are you coming to
perform here we saw your nail salon
video and
had 12 minutes of material at the time
because I just wrote jokes in a free
class I had no desire to be a comedian
right it was just the thing I was doing
for fun and it cuz it was free in the
next thing you know my spot gets blown
up and everybody is like oh come perform
here and so I end up writing more
material and what happened is I get an
agent right
I start getting messages from all these
network executives assistants because
nobody knew how to get ahold of me
because I didn't have an agent yet right
so I would get a message on MySpace that
was like yes it was like hey I'm the
assistant to so-and-so at NBC at CBS at
all these networks and they're like they
want to meet you because they saw the
nail salon video so by March I ended up
meeting with like everybody in Hollywood
and by May I had auditioned for MADtv
and booked it and then throughout the
summer I ended up writing more material
because I'm like what comedy clubs want
me to come and perform there so let me
write more jokes so by the end of the
year I was touring as a comedian and I
was headlining and I had written to at
least 45 minutes of material and I would
just put up like four or five comics
ahead of me to like fill up the show
hours you know and but that's how it
went in 2007 nothing to my name in
January no opportunities no money to the
end of the year I was on MADtv I was
touring as a comedian and my life had
completely changed and this video went
viral and blew up my spot wow that's
that's like the story that like what
everybody wants to do now anybody that
puts a video on YouTube well what see
actually this is the launch of what
influencers are now right you know so
it's like but you you went into actually
a specific career which is stand-up
comedy but then the cut to say you know
cut to four years later right then it
was like oh this is something yeah they
started making vine and you know videos
on Instagram and like all these things
started to happen and then at least now
it's a whole I'm saying that what you
did sort of launch the industry in
comedy because that's what you have now
when you see these influences like I had
amanda cerny on here you know yeah she
started a similar
the thing where she was like I'm doing
videos and they say ya know I have 25
million follow
that's insane it's crazy so it's like
it's just one of those things are like
you know we all trying to capture the
magic look I'm doing a podcast I'm
thinking like at any time one of these
could be the one where people go I
really want to watch this guy or it
could be this slow bill that is just a
little section of fans and that's all
that it is right it's you never know
yeah who's watching who's listening
what's gonna be the one like it's just a
matter of showing up each day you show
up to do your job you show up and be
present in the moment you show up and be
creative you show up and be the best
version of yourself you operate in your
highest self you show up and do the work
to get rid of the things that are
holding you back and sometimes those
things look like self doubt insecurity
and how do you confront those things in
your life and it's about showing up for
yourself yes it is look at you and
you're like I said you've always been
clean you make when you make that choice
for you like I want to be a clean comic
or didn't even it wasn't even a choice
like that it was just like this is who I
am it was not even a choice this one
saying it was this is who I am now it's
a choice
let me explain so early on when I
started I was very conservative in my
life in my faith in my just super Krish
like very Christian girl you know I mean
and like would not drink alcohol like
nothing and I have evolved as a woman in
my faith in just in my life period and
certain things that I felt were bad or
taboo or whatever I don't necessarily
feel the same way anymore like I don't
feel like if I say like I don't feel
like if I say a cuss word I'm going to
hell yeah man I mean like it's so now
though here's my my thing now is I have
branded myself a certain way so I have a
loyal fan base that is used to they
expect a certain something from me a
certain product from me like when
you go to Burger King you know what
you're getting when you go to talk about
you know what you're getting like you
don't want to go talk about and all of a
sudden they're like oh we serve
hamburgers now you're like Oh even
though they do well I was kind of
Rocko's that's weird
so I'm at this place where I I love the
fact that people can bring their kids to
my show and they feel okay bringing
their kids people can bring their
grandparents to my show and they feel
okay bringing their grandparents they're
not they don't have to feel like
embarrassed if I start talking about a
certain topic or if I'm dropping f-bombs
and they're like all no grannies
offended we shouldn't a broader like I I
don't play to the kids in the audience
and I don't play to the grandparents I
play to myself but you just have an act
that is universal exactly exactly so I
keep it that way for them and I I tell
you who like I love how like Brian Regan
can work completely clean of that guy
and then Jim Gaffigan who works clean
and then he can drop an f-bomb every now
and then but he still hasn't lost his
fan base like it just keeps growing and
growing I feel like eventually I would
like to hear from Brian Regan territory
to Jim Gaffigan territory where it's
gonna be a clean show but every now and
then you might get a little curse here
and there do you feel like if you curse
the whole crowds gonna go baby maybe
like 50 50 50 50 of the crowd like some
will leave and be like I'm gonna pray
for you and the others will be like not
even note is it yeah well that's cool
like you you'd you talk about being
Christian a lot you yeah even in this
conversation you said it like a few
times is that from your family have you
always been a woman of faith we didn't
grow up like in childhood childhood
going to church or anything it was it
wasn't really until my parents got
divorced that we started going to like
youth group and stuff like that which at
the time youth group saved my life and
has helped shaped Who I am today and
there's certain things that I I take
from my childhood from my background of
faith that I applied to my life and I
say this is a principle that I live
bye and then there's other certain
things where you know what I don't know
that I stand by that anymore and let's
just move forward and it's like little
things like this that we're talking
about just evolving don't that's dope I
appreciate that like you know you know
some people are religious some people
aren't some people are people of faith
or some people are like you know I'm
spiritual I'm not you know whatever it
is like that but it's like you know the
the core of it is like I want to live a
good life I want to be a nice person I
want to treat people well and represent
myself well so even taking religion out
of it living like that there's nothing
wrong with it yeah totally
and it's like I used to be the person
back in the day where if somebody said
oh I'm spiritual and I just want to be a
good person like back then old school
Angela would be like well that's not
enough you have to have Jesus like it
has to be dude I get that your rituals
but it has to be Jesus like that's how I
in my teenage years in early 20s it was
like okay that's great that your
spiritual and I feel like now I'm at a
place where I'm I just I'm like listen
guys God is real I feel and there's some
people who are like no there's no such
thing as God and that's cool to you
that's your belief I feel like God is
real and if I can encourage someone to
get reconnected with themself and with
God and at some point all the sudden
wake up and realize like whoa like God
is so big in my life and whether you say
Jesus or not I would just love to
encourage people to reconnect with your
Creator in whatever way that works for
you and then for those who are like I
don't have a creator then this doesn't
apply to you I like that so you
originally from San Jose I know that
because every time you go to San Jose
you sell out 85 weekends in a row you
know Angela Johnson's here for seven
weeks is a residency yeah yeah you don't
even with a resin healthy Santa
a residency at the improv that's funny
yeah did you I know you wanted to be I
know you wanted to be like an R&B singer
you said that one no you lyin cuz you
told me you were like I'm working on my
album
bone quickly yes she came out with a
full-on album yes my Angela I have never
thought like oh I'm gonna come out with
my own actually now I do think about it
but back then I didn't but my character
bone Qui Qui she came out with and she
got signed to Warner Brothers Records
and came out with a full on communique
pop album she has songs like imma cut
you this is what the thing comes out
right now all the song exactly her
Christmas album she came out with a
Christmas EP called Mary Hood miss her
hit single was called deck the hoes and
so yeah that she has music videos and
songs and all that so that's another
thing that actually that leads us into
that because it's like okay so you had
the you know so the nails long beard I
blew you up like MADtv then then it was
like this Kerri yes this character that
was like was there ever a time that you
felt like the character was like
overtaking everything all the time
oh really what tell me how that felt so
I feel like for a while I built her
brand and that was good it was a great
season of my life I got to tour as this
character with a live band and backup
dancers and like it was an amazing fun
show that I got to be a music artist I
got to be like ghetto Beyonce for a
little while and it was so fun and I was
like a hood rat version of Beyonce and
it was a really great experience but it
got to a point for me where I wanted to
grow in other areas of my life in being
an actress not playing that character
but the more I would build her brand the
more I felt kind of stuck in her brand
so I had to just kind of put her on the
back burner for a little while and grow
me in other areas that I wanted to grow
and I'm still trying to grow you know
just had Frank Caliendo annika podcast
and he was he was similarly talking
about like trying to break away from
just being the guy that does impressions
right you know and it was just really
interesting to hear him like just talk
about like you know cuz you know he
became very wealthy because of that and
it was like how do you like how do I go
away from the can I go away from right I
mean we used like so it was there a
moment to be like am i more you you
decided I am more than this you know
right this chick is going to go away you
know like we did great car accident and
then now yeah I keep telling everybody
she's on vacation yeah
so if I do like radio interviews or
whoever and everybody wants to talk
about bon Qui Qui I say she's on
vacation and then I redirect to
something about me like this is my time
right really she's not here right now
yes so that must have been okay because
it cuz it's it's a war because it's like
you know the one is really paying the
bills and no life great and then but
you're like but I can do this right
totally and it's the same thing with my
material like this nail salon joke like
I know that I'm more than this joke but
every show that I do people want to hear
that joke and so at first I would fight
it and I'm like I'm so tired of this
joke I don't want to have to do this for
the rest of my life now I'm at a place
where I'm like I will do this joke for
the rest of my life because it's like a
thank you at this point it's like this
joke made me who I am today this joke is
what bought me my house this joke is
what keeps my family afloat and so I'm
not just gonna abandon it and also I
know that this joke brings joy to a lot
of people and if I'm really about what I
say I'm about which is bringing joy to
people yes it's about my career and
elevating to the next level and and and
getting you know more money more success
more just elevate next level next level
yes all of that plays a part of it but
at the end of the day the reason why I
get on stage and tell a joke is because
I want to connect with another human
being in the audience
I want to bring them joy and laughter is
medicine for sure and we get to be
doctors basically we get to travel the
world with a prescription and we bring
this medicine to people who need it who
are hurting whether it's they're going
through a divorce they just lost a loved
one it's stressful times at work they're
doubting them sever they're dealing with
you come and bring an hour and a half of
joy to them and that's what it's about
and that's what makes it worth getting
up at 4:00 a.m. to go through TSA to get
on a plane that's delayed and then you
sit on the tarmac and then you get in
now you missed your soundcheck because
your flight was delayed and then you
have to rush there and after do a meet
and greet with like 50 people and it's
just like you you want to like eat
something you want to take a nap because
you've been up since 3:00 in the morning
and all these things what makes it worth
it is that connection that human
connection that relationship which is
what makes anything worth it in life
I totally agree with you I remember
being in Detroit one time and this guy
come it was like few years ago you know
and then this guy he walks up to me says
hey man I just want to thank you for
coming I lost my job three weeks ago and
I needed this tonight and I was like
thank you like you're somebody you lost
your job and you're like whatever little
money you have you spent on this ticket
again
no no meaner or just like even if it
wasn't to buy a ticket you and they let
him in free and he's buying drinks and
well yeah it's like so you you know you
used me as your way to like feel better
I mean that's like such a I know what
you're saying I feel like you have this
sense of responsibility now for sure you
know instead of a say a feeling of like
that a lot of performers have of
entitlement right you know yeah there's
a time when we feel like I deserve to be
hae-in I'm not saying I'm immune to that
either none of us are immune to it
there's seasons there's phases there's
days there's whatever it may be it could
be as simple as you're operating out of
this place of like gratitude and
whatever and and and I'll just begin in
my voice my terms like let's say
I get to a city and I'm gonna go to a
show and I'm I'm remembering why I woke
up so early and I'm like okay it's about
the fans and I just met somebody in the
lobby who gave me one of those stories
about I just lost fill in the blank I'm
so happy to be here and then that makes
you feel like yeah I'm doing something
with purpose this is awesome this is why
I do what I do and then you open up your
phone and you start scrolling and then
you see your friend that just booked a
movie you see your friend that just got
a new TV show you see your friend that
just sold her next hour you see your
friend that is now has like 5 million
followers you see like all these things
and then you can easily slip right back
into man I work hard too I should have
that I should buh bah bah bah bah and
then you slip back into this entitlement
zone and that is not productive nothing
productive comes out of entitlement it's
about switching your perspective and
getting back realigning alignment in
such a powerful word what are you
aligning yourself with and so it's in
those moments where I can find myself
caught in that circle and have to
realign and refocus and be like ok ok
why am i doing what I'm doing my journey
my lane stay focused put your blinders
on stay focus on what's ahead of you
because that's what matters
yeah and it can be hard I mean it's like
I know even like I'm doing this podcast
game right and then I see all these if
you were doing podcasts and your whole
you it's hard not to focus on like how
come I don't have that many followers in
here at the same time as me or a person
is nat nat mean just like but then it's
like then you have these moments where
like yesterday i have a peel box i
where's my peel box i got this card and
it says private oh ok
i'm safe or something about oh is it
gonna be some no but you know what it
was it was this nice card with a nice
note from somebody and said to me you
know christ sing a lot on the thing and
i sing on my gaming things and they're
like please this is they sent me a
hundred dollars and it said this is for
your album fund please start this album
and and then like it didn't this long
letter about like oh you know some i
love your show because you know it just
helps me and all these kind of things
and i go oh
oh yeah that's why we're doing this you
know it's like the special connection
that you get with even just the one
person want like if you're watching
right now and you enjoy watching me and
the interactions I have with with but my
guests and I go I get you I know you're
out there and I appreciate you and it's
like that the thing is this but we're
always like we live in this business
that's a results business yes so we're
always looking at like you know it's
like what
there's no finish line but we keep
seeing rewards that were like well I
want that reward but it's like I'm not
on that race yeah I mean oh I hear you
to the point where I remember one time I
was scrolling through Instagram and I
saw two of my friends at the time had
posted that they were directing an
episode of their show that they were on
or someone else's show right and I
remember thinking in my mind like see
how I'm supposed to I should be
directing an episode like I I want to
direct an episode but I'm not even on a
TV show to direct an episode and then I
had to pause for a second and I was like
wait a minute hold on Angela when in
your life have you ever wanted to be a
director you do not want to be a
director oh I know when it was two
minutes ago when I saw when I saw
somebody else doing it and I had to
check myself and I'm like wait wait wait
I don't wanna be a director it's just
that looks like Klout that looks like
success that looks like I'm winning that
looks like I'm doing it so all the
sudden I was like oh yeah then I gotta
be a director too and I was like wait
not I don't I don't wanna be directory I
don't care like I want to be an actor
like I'm still trying to get on a TV
show I don't know any be a director but
it's so hard sometimes to stay focused
on your own lane and what you're doing
and be able to celebrate your friends
and I can honestly say that when I see
my friends succeed it makes me happy and
I cheer them on and I promote them and I
say hey my friend has a new TV show
everybody go watch it
my friend is doing this and I can do
that
without resentment I can do it without
any kind of motive behind it other than
celebrate my friend because I believe
that there is room for all of us and all
of us and right now it's that person's
season it's there yes right now so let's
celebrate there yes in faith that one
day I'll have a yes too but right now
it's there yes so we can celebrate them
just because they got a yes doesn't mean
they took away your yes they just have
their own but isn't it funny to though
that like while you're in your Lane
doing your thing achieving certain
things there's it's crazy because
there's still people in other lanes
going I want to do it how to set up his
sound gear and all that and then little
do they know nobody done taht you can't
hear to echo like it's me figuring it
out there's no echo sorry to interrupt
guys but I got to do some business and
talk to you once again about my bookie
this football season is going to be one
of the best ever
Antonio Browns with the Raiders living
on bells with the Jets Odell Beckham was
with Cleveland look I'm putting my money
down on a lot of games and I don't
always want to go someplace to do it you
could do it right from your hand my
bookie is the place to bet on football
every single weekend and they have a
handicapping contest in the first place
it's guaranteed to win at least $100,000
and it only costs $100 to enter all you
got to do is pick five NFL games against
the spread every week to climb the
leaderboard and score your share of the
huge cast prize pool listen I'm not
telling you to bet all your money make
sure you bet responsibly but if you if
you are gonna bet my bookie is the place
to go I would recommend the service to
all my listeners it's been good to me
that's why my bookie is always the right
play you bet you win they pay my bookie
has live in game betting on every NFL
game they've got the most rewarding
player perks in the business and for
your fantasy guys out there you can even
at the over-under on how many fantasy
points a player will score each week now
that's absolutely my favorite part about
my bookie because I've been playing
fantasy sports for like 20 years and
like you want to support the real team
you want to cheer for the real team so
now you can bet on the real team
you can also bet on your team bet how
many fantasy points you're gonna get
how many fantasy points these players
gonna get over/under so now it just
makes the whole football experience you
know even better it's fun I love my
bookie up to $1,000 first deposit bonus
double your first deposit use promo code
riffin to activate the offer visit my
bookie online today
that's my bookie m YB o o ki e.com and
don't forget to use the promo code
riffin when creating your account to
claim the bonus guys bet when get paid
now let's get back to the podcast and I
hope you're enjoying it and don't forget
my bookie riffing on their code oh
that's funny you know what's oh I always
think that's weird about you is that a
weird way to say what's weird about I
never see you at in the comedy scene
anxiety insecurity fear and exhaustion
there it is you can't there isn't and
more honest answer than that all those
things we still I still feel and I'm in
the comedy scene so I totally get what
you're saying by the site but I just I
was just so curious to me it was like
cuz it it's like because then you become
this enigma you become this like you're
out here you know it's like oh she
started on out on some different path
and then she's off on her own doing the
thing she never comes to the Improv
never comes to the comedy store never
comes to the Laugh Factory you know it's
like a you know it's like it's like it's
like you're outside of the Brotherhood
mm-hmm and I feel like I have um not
resent is not the word I have
I hope there's times when I look back
and I go man I wish I was a part of the
club I wish I was there hanging out with
all the other comics and like making
friends and like I'll see pictures of
like Adam Sandler back when he was
coming up and it's like him and Sarah
and like all them and it's like I wish I
could have a photo when I'm older of
like back when we used to just hang out
at the club and I don't because of those
things that I said because I have let
those things hold me back from coming
and investing in that and also I mean
there's a couple of things like I can
lean on this as an excuse button or
there's also some validity to what I'm
about to say when I get home like I'm on
the road so much when I get home I have
a few days off I want to spend that with
my friends who I never get to see my
niece and nephew that I never get to see
I want to invest in like normal things
like go grocery shopping with my husband
go on a date night with my husband so I
don't want to be in the comedy club when
I just came from doing so many comedy
shows all across the country so there's
part of that like I'm here today is I
want to be there I want to be with my
family and what truly matters to me like
relationship with those who are gonna be
there for me when I'm having a rough day
when I'm sad and when I like I need a
dollar because I went broke or something
you know I mean like I want to vest in
those relationships but at the same time
sometimes I lean on that as an excuse
and even if I do have time to get to the
club I'll get nervous and I'll get
anxiety and I'll be like but I don't
know anybody what oh what is that though
like what are you at nervous about what
is the anxiety about um I haven't made
relationships so I'm nervous that when I
get there like I don't know the doorman
I don't know whoever is booking this
room I don't know all these other comics
and like I should know them and then
what if I get there and and people don't
like me
that old high-school thing of like what
if people don't like me and Here I am
like working on Syria by yourself you
know exactly that's what it feels like
imagining walking in by yourself and
then everybody turns and looks at you
with your trade you're like oh I'll just
go sit over here in the corner then and
it's like I have to work myself up to go
and eat like just last week I went and I
did three spots I did the Laugh Factory
and two at the improv and I was texting
with cristela cristela Alonzo when I was
on my way there and I was like yeah I'm
pretending to be a real comic tonight
and I'm gonna go do some some club spots
around town and she was laughing at me
and um and I've talked to her about I've
talked to Eliza about it and there was
times when I would call Liza cuz I would
watch her go to the club all the time
she's available
every off day she's at the club and I
called her one time I was like hey um
can I just roll with you one time and
just be like your plus one and just like
kind everything like why don't I wanted
to watch and learn like just follow you
as you walk through the showroom as you
walk through the greenroom as you walk
through like let me just see how you
operate in these environments so I could
learn because I never did it I never
hung out at the clubs because I was
afraid people didn't like me because my
video blew up and I became popular and
so now people were judging me and and
people were hating on me or whatever
it wasn't affect you it did yeah it did
and I let my insecurities and my fear
hold me back and so now I'm at this
place in my life where I'm actually
trying to just come and show up and and
I enjoy it when I'm there and I see
other comics that I never get to see and
like this last weekend I saw Chris
D'Elia and we got to catch up a little
bit and see some comics that I haven't
got to meet in person but we see each
other on social media and it's one of
those words like we think we know each
other but we're like hey so nice to
finally meet you
fifteen years later you know
like so I'm trying good for you
Thanks I know it's harness and thank you
for like being that vulnerable about you
know your feelings and stuff because you
know it's like that that's just you know
it is being a comic is to be insecure is
to be like you know have these like you
know like we're always like paranoid
great instead of looking at all the
people say it's like a crowd it's like
we did every Connolly says this you know
you got a crowd full of 300 people 299
of them are laughing but there's this
one person who is just arms cross friend
brought him and he don't want to be
there in mid joke they're going like
this uh-huh
right you know you're like I'm gonna get
that person just celebrate all these
other people who are loving you we just
fixate on the one person who is not
having a good time and I remember there
was this one time in a show I saw this
guy and he was having the worst time
right in the front of course he was
having the worst time of his life but
his wife that he came with was having
the best time and I felt so bad for her
because you know how when you go and you
experience something you want to share
it with people so like somebody says
something funny you want to look to your
friend and be like oh my god was that
not just the funniest thing you heard
and she kept doing that to her husband
she'd be laughing and look over at him
and he was having the worst time and
she'd be like I hate that I was broken
for her like no for me like if I go to a
movie and like I move let's say could
this happen to me I wanted to go see
Karate Kid to remake
okay James Smith huh and there's this
great scene with Jackie Chan beats up
the car and he has just like I was like
it was his Oscar moment you don't mean
I mean I'm quiet yes I look over just my
friend that I went with and he just is
like nothing I'm like are you a soulless
monster uh-huh do not moves by what's
happening to Jan right habitude as a
child yeah family died in an accident
with this thing right are you just gonna
see here like nothing's happening he
just didn't get it and I thought to
myself oh you know what I don't know if
I could be friends with somebody that is
it moved by the things I'm moved by or
at least understands why I moved yeah
cuz that is so awkward so here's
somebody in the front row trying to
enjoy themselves and they looking over
at Dave what yeah oh it was I felt real
bad for her and I had to purposely
change my focus from him because I was
doing that thing that you say where we
tried to like there's that one person
this next joke right here he going for
sure laugh at this while watch honey and
I give it and I look at him and he's
still not laughing I'm like damn and
then it starts messing with my head and
so I'm like okay you know what let me
just forget about this dude let me and
then I switch my focus to her and I was
like giving it to her like you poor
thing like your partner he don't even
want to like be celebrating the fact
that you are experiencing why'd you
acknowledge that because that always
that always helps that always makes that
person kind of go they kind of go oh
okay I'm sorry
you know what did he do did he react
what okay so I talked to him after the
show right so it wasn't during the show
like I find out she cheated on him and
he's mad right something something
happened but so after the show they came
through the meet-and-greet and he was
all smiles like lit up and and she comes
and gives me a hug and he like shakes my
hand is like man that was a great show
and I was like you liked it yeah and he
was like and I was like cuz you look
like you were having the worst time the
entire time Oh like just kind of like
laugh it off and now they feel awkward
or something yeah because maybe he was
having the worst time and he's just
faking it for this picture
about the toy or he just like has a
horrible face and that's just what his
like I have RBF sometime like resting
[ __ ] I have that real bad people
think I hate them and I'm like no no
this is just what my face looks like I
know what you mean so I'm like maybe he
just had some real strong RBF going on
alright let's pivot so not going to the
clubs not necessarily being in the
comedy scene you I don't know if you've
how was your experience going through me
- how it affected your comedy how it
affected your life I mean is like have
that you know cuz it cuz I guess a male
comic I felt like damn well I can't
stand being lumped in with everybody
damn be like okay you're male comic so
then that means you know it's like it's
like a flirt divided it it doesn't work
like that you know you know I mean so
it's like how do you think comedy has
changed you know are we more thoughtful
or any more considerate or like you know
or is it like the as a female comic are
you like well this is what we've been
dealing with now y'all finally see let
me tell you a story that happened to me
one time when I was first coming up as a
young comic I was doing this gig in
Santa Barbara was it aunt area somewhere
driving on the 101 North right and there
was like four other comics and the guy
who booked me for it I saw him at
remember three of clubs when there used
to be a night like Monday nights at
three of clubs there's nothing like that
right well I would I would go up there
often and I met this guy there who was
very nice and he got a private party
somebody's birthday party and he needed
to book like three or four comedians and
he is like you can you do undo it yeah
sure you can roll with me and my fiance
you can come with us and we'll drive out
there perfect let's do that right and
again like I'm brand-new I'm still like
insecure like I don't I'm trying to
pretend I know how this comedy world
works but like yeah sure I'll go do like
a road gig with you fun right and last
minute hey my my fiance is getting off
of work late so I have to wait with her
but I'm gonna send you ahead with this
other comic I had never met this guy
before but I'm trying to be like down
like this is what comedians do we like
roll together and that's what we do so I
go and our deal was like I was parking
at his house and we were gonna roll in
his car and drive there so um I park in
his house and I I there was no parking
like right in front of his apartment was
way down the street and anyways that
that's a detail I'm going to come back
to later on so I'm
with him to this private party
somebody's backyard and it's just we're
talking and whatever it is and we get to
this party I go up first I do my jokes
it's a good reception every laughs a
good time he goes up after me his whole
opening like five minutes is about how
he rode to the party with me and he just
wanted to jerk off the whole time with
me sitting next to him so he thought it
was funny yeah he know he's being funny
hmm he's bombing bombing I hope not one
person's laughing now one person's
laughing everyone is feeling awkward for
me yeah I just got onstage
yeah and he he one of those things where
like you either abort or you double down
he double down and just dug a deeper
hole and was just nasty and very vividly
talking about me and it was just real
inappropriate and I remember feeling
violated feeling like unsafe I don't
even know what to do and I'm by myself I
don't know anyone here and I remember
hiding in the kitchen away from all the
people I'm like getting emotional
thinking about I remember hiding and the
guy who is his birthday he came in the
kitchen and he was like are you okay and
well yeah I'm fine like trying to like
shake it off and I'm really fine and I
had to ride home with that guy in the
car
and I remember feeling like real just
scared and like oh my god I'm so grossed
out like I don't even know what to do
and I remember I got on my cell phone
and I just kept calling friend after
friend the whole drive home it was like
hour and a half or two hours and I
remember just whenever that person had
to him I would hang up and I would call
somebody else just so I could not have
to look at him or talk to him or
anything and when we got to his
apartment again like I said I was not
parked anywhere near his apartment
except no parking I was way down the
street and
there was a parking spot for him right
in front of the apartment that he could
have taken but he didn't take it he was
like oh no no I'll just trade spots with
you and I was like but I'm Way far away
from your apartment just take that one
and he's like no no no that's totally
fine right and he was trying to keep me
in the car longer and so he finally
drops me off at my car and I go to get
out and he goes hey so um do you want to
come up and I was dumbfounded I was are
you what and I was just like no no I
don't and I rushed into my car and I
just got out of that situation because
honestly like I don't know what could
happen yeah yeah yeah and it was just
inappropriate and it was violating it
was not fair and it was not okay but he
thought like in the name of comedy like
I could do that like it's just come it's
just jokes you're a comic you should be
able to handle it you know what I mean
and stuff like that that it's not okay
if you had to do it differently would
you respond to him differently or like
what do you think in that situation like
not to say this is not your fault at all
right you know I'm just saying I'm just
saying so if anybody else is in a
situation like this or like what do you
what would you think you would have done
differently speak up but in that moment
I like my personality type I don't like
confrontation right so there may be a
lot of women or men out there that are
like I don't like confrontation
let me just ignore it like what I did
let me just get on the phone and ignore
it yeah like now if I could do things
differently I mean who knows like I
didn't have a ride home right it was
like I'm sure it's before the days of
uber and even then like a two-hour uber
I'm a broke leg obviously doing like
this gig for 50 bucks you know what I
mean so I was like I didn't have much
choice at that point and then if I do
call him out and be like how dare you
woo-woo-woo and then get in the car with
him what if he just pissed off and then
left me there like it's so many things
like what could I have done differently
don't know what I guess I'm asking that
just to point out the point that like
you know there in some cases you did the
best thing you could do to feel safe and
as I that's nothing you could do it's
like what am I supposed to do not get a
ride home right some guy that's stronger
than me and say so this is the feeling
that I'm starting to realize I'm seen as
like you know cuz like you know from a
different perspective it's like yeah
you're just some small girl and you're
in a car with some guy you don't even
really know who just was like completely
inappropriate and now you're like I just
got to get home to my car so I did the
hell away from this person so that just
that was like without the guy even
touching you or anything like that was
like equivalent to you know just one of
the worst experiences you've experienced
in comedy so it's like damn and Here I
am years later and it still affects you
yeah yeah so well yeah I I see that you
know I open her you know what I mean I
mean for me it's like you know like I'm
just a bit I'm a big dude I'm six-three
whatever it is so it's like I don't even
know the effect that I might hey you
know that's the thing that you don't
realize I mean as a guy I'm just
admitting that to myself this is just me
speaking for me it's like I don't know
what I might say or do there make
somebody uncomfortable I wish somebody
I'm the kind of person and you could be
like yo that made me uncomfortable and
I'd be like oh [ __ ] I didn't realize
that right I wish people were like that
but at the same time I totally
understand why you're sitting here being
like how am I gonna tell you I don't
know you know you're you know who knows
which how you might react like that so
it's like that's the Wow well there it
is guys you know so to answer your
question I don't know I feel like with
my material nothing I never was talking
about anything that the me to movement
would have shifted what I talked about
bump scenes has affected I guess that's
more for guys like me I always feel like
I like I liked it because it made me
more thoughtful maybe be like okay if I
want to talk about this and say this I
means I have to like find a way to still
say what I want to say but not come
across whatever it is but you can't win
for losing though it doesn't even matter
but at least you try to cover yourself
yeah and there's no there's no outline
there's no recipe there's no
this is the right way to do it and it's
a shifting time that we're in so it's
like I feel like I have grace for people
as we are shifting and learning and I
have grace for men who are learning like
oh this is actually inappropriate and
for those who want to learn because
there's some guys that can be like
you're just too sensitive like somebody
some guy could be hearing that story
that I just said and they're like so
what's wrong with that you're just too
sensitive was just a joke and that's
where they're at and so they don't have
a desire to like evolve and play fair or
anything like that but for someone who
is like my bad I didn't know that was
offensive I'm not gonna do that anymore
I have grace for that person I'm gonna
try to ruin that person's life and be
like they should never be hired on any
TV show ever again like canceled culture
I'm no I'm not trying to cancel people
but I do want to educate well just in
comedy in general I feel like this I'm
fine with saying oh I'm sorry you are
offended as long as there's some from
you to say I know you didn't mean
offense that's what we're missing
and sometimes in people's conversation
about jokes about anything you know it's
like you know they just go oh you know
they judge you based off you might say
something your act and they'll be like
oh okay you're a racist right like
excuse me this is the environment for
jokes saying things that are like
inappropriate or say pushing the
envelope or like you know so if you
can't understand that that's the
environment for that and then you could
come back and be like okay that just
wasn't my cup of tea
right right but it shouldn't be like I'm
now judged you know so harshly I mean
you're not to say that what happened to
you did this it doesn't necessarily
apply to that because this is just
somebody with no self-awareness right of
like the thing because even if he would
have done that I mean he even if he
would have said that and you get this
reaction from the crowd it's like you're
not reading that this isn't going well
and then like and another thing she was
like you're in the car not
to talk to me like I'm the kind of
person I'd be like oh [ __ ]
somewhere I messed up here hey cuz I
remember going on a Tribble run you
never a teenage rebel runs you just
skipped all the stuff that's why people
mad at you so mad you didn't go through
what dudes did you pay yeah you should
have struggled nobody say it is what it
is we have our struggles at our
different times but so you know you
drive around Montana okay you know so
there was this female comic I would I
forgot her name I don't even know she's
around anymore
but anyway Dave Tripp the owner the
company he calls me says Eric just
female comic she wants to do a bunch of
Tribble runs so I want you to go with
her I want you to like be the headliner
and you take her around you know and I
was like you know I'm like well I mean I
don't wanna babysit like well you know
on my mind I'm like what is this about
you know but I totally got it when we
were on the road it just was like but
then I totally got it because by the way
I don't feel safe sometimes when I'm on
the road so knows I'm at someplace and
I'm like I just realized said that I'm
here by myself anything could happen to
me who's gonna call like sometimes you
got a club there's no security this
drunk people acting up and I'm saying
you're like wait a minute this can go
wrong at any time so then okay I'm
thinking here we are driving eight hours
a day to go to these little crazy towns
in Montana here's this woman by herself
we're at crazy bars it's not like clubs
we're doing like the bar we're doing a
show in the bar of a hotel or like weird
and I'm thinking to myself oh yeah this
must be at the time was the first time I
thought oh this must be hard to be a
woman in comedy that's when that's when
you realize I was like oh this Bobby
really uncomfortable I mean even if
you're with another woman it's just two
women out here like you know like would
I'm so you know I was like damn it's
like you know that was just an eye
opener even back then so you know and
then when you hear these experiences but
you know it's like I just I when I I
feel like people need to tread lightly
how they talk about it because they
don't seem to like talk a lot about how
it affects
you know people of color hmm you know
it's like all these people that are
talking about it or screaming from the
mountains I always seem to be like you
know 1% or white women you know what I
mean I'm like you know there's a lot of
other people being affected in different
ways that don't have the platform to say
whatever the hell they want to say I
just all I do is do me to the best of my
ability and I share my truth my story my
experiences and how you receive it is on
you yeah well I think you know I think
you're doing a fantastic job at that you
know thank you
I mean I feel like our business is like
a marathon and in these things that we
get is those people that have the water
while you're right that's what it is so
somebody might have like some Gatorades
I was just water be that a bonus yeah so
it's like it's just like a weird weird a
weird process you know I mean so I know
you're married you know your your your
husband sitting over there
no this is Jackie's husband Jackie's -
that's what her husband ah comes to me
that confused me a lot because I was
like you know cuz good the way to remail
said it was something about I'm sending
my husband okay this is know so my
assistant is Jackie and she usually
comes with me okay everywhere her
husband but Eddie also works as me as
well we both travel with me I do I got
my whole crew but it's funny because any
guy that I'm with people assume that's
my husband yeah and the one who gets it
the most is mal Hall because my husband
is Puerto Rican and he has an afro and
tall black guy I'm walking with and then
I'm with mal Hall tall black guy I'm
walking with so people come in airports
people come up to us all the time and
they're they tell Mel I love your music
and then he goes oh I'm not Manuel and
but it's like I'm with Mal all the time
he's been opening for me for years and
so we're just used to it now is people
come up to him and come I just go okay
and they compliment him for his music
all the time thank you
yeah and then my brother gets it if I'm
with my brother somewhere people always
assume he's my husband and I go grouse
my brother thinks though Eddie pretty
much any guy that I'm with they're like
oh nice to meet your husband the black
you know what that's a testament to you
Larry just something just something
people like nobody's thinking they
saying
oh she's with a guy I know what kind of
person she is so that guy must be her
husband nobody's just side piece every
guy you're with that is a compliment
that's cool I don't know are you uh I do
I mean I kids in the future or like what
do you like in you know I have my child
here in his bag right now my my little
fur baby who I love with all my heart
and we've always said we didn't want
kids but now I'm getting older I'm 37
Eric right first time you know I guess I
guess I'm bringing it up just to say
like you know you you want like if you
watch the WNBA or any like female
athlete right you see them and they're
doing their female athlete thing but
then they're like I'm also a woman and I
got to put a baby in here just gonna be
a mom
when Serena was pregnant and all that
kind of stuff is like has like being a
family being a wife and a mom how is how
is that been like if you had those
aspirations at the same time as you has
you're like you know I want to be a star
I want to be in movies I want to be on
TV yes don't want to Angela Johnson show
I still want you know to me yeah like
how do you balance that cuz there's a
guy thank God we don't gotta worry about
I'll be back when it when's the baby due
okay oh my gosh oh no I am I'm still
very much chasing my dreams and not
ready to put my dreams to the side to
raise a child
and unfortunately I'm getting older so I
I would hope that I would have caught
those feelings by now but I haven't but
I I have hope when I look at people like
Eva Longoria who didn't have her first
child till she was 40 or 41 you know and
even my cousin my cousin didn't have her
first child till she was 41 so I think
like kind of maybe I have time and to
decide if I want kids later on but right
now I'm just enjoying my life as it is
and I have my dog my husband you have a
village of people though you're not
gonna be able to I do listen my husband
and I we have a house we have one two
three four bedrooms five bathrooms and
it's just him him and I so you would
think like oh that's way too much house
for you guys we have people in that
house all the dream it's like a whole
ocean it's a hotel it's always either my
family are from his friends coming in
for a writing session or a meeting and
so like we have two guest rooms they're
always booked out like it's we have a
calendar like a front desk we're like Oh
welcome to at one point I did print out
a little sheet of if you're here like
because sometimes people see their when
we're not there and just like yeah you
can stay at our house or whatever and
it's like okay if you're here on a
Wednesday that's garbage and I take the
garbages out to the street you know like
full
and this is how it is to like it's an
air B&B got a little bed and breakfast
you know but I don't know we so we have
lots of family and friends that were
surrounded by and and it fills our cup
for now so until then that's great so
you know in closing we say so 10 years
later yeah are you happy yeah I'm
grateful
yeah very grateful it still blows my
mind that people want to hear what I
have to say and they'll pay to hear what
I have to say they'll buy back the crazy
part that's nuts like that is nuts to me
because it's been 12 years on the road
and I have been fortunate enough to say
that it's been 12 years of very
successful shows and I just sometimes
I'll stop and I'll look at my career or
I'll look at my life or I'll just be
sitting in the kitchen
and I look out the window out the view
and I think about like I can't believe
this is my life I can't believe that I
woke up to drink some coffee to go to
record a podcast leader and that's my
life like now that I'm so grateful so
grateful so 10 years later yes I'm happy
I'm grateful I'm still in awe I'm still
very much like wow this this is
incredible that's great you know when I
really noticed that too is like if it's
a friend or a family member or like an
acquaintance in and then there'd live in
their life and they might say to you
they might say like what are you doing
today and you say that some coffee I'm
going to just podcasts later then I go
to the dog park I'm not sure and they're
like luck cards had to say no boo-boo it
wasn't luck yeah you know I did a lot of
work right and then also again in the
world of social media or whatever like
people only see the highlight reel they
only see like so they didn't so if I
could on Instagram today
I went to go get coffee and I went to go
record a podcast and then I went and I
had lunch with my friends and people
could look at that be like man like
that's the life right there they didn't
see my anxiety of waking up and looking
at my ticket sales for my tour made like
oh wow like people aren't coming ok and
they didn't see me getting in an
argument with my husband or they didn't
see me like getting the phone call from
my agent like hey you know that role you
really wanted you didn't book it they
gave it to somebody else like they don't
see the rejection they don't see the
sacrifice they don't see the hurt they
don't see the wounds that were
constantly getting to like get this
tough skin so that we can have the
freedom to just go record a podcast and
go to lunch and come home right well
said well I wish you all the success
don't stay on the marathon and keep you
know keep getting those things keep
getting that's how it been sometimes
well you know we'll take a break at the
finish line whenever that is but in the
meantime we could just enjoy this
journey yep
well guys make sure you subscribe like I
want to have all of Angela's information
on the on the little description area
right there so you can like find her and
you know thanks for watching please
share subscribe like do all that stuff
keep listening I love all the comments
even the haters everything makes you
better
oh sometimes YouTube is like one of the
most evil places YouTube and Twitter are
like reddit is the worst oh I don't even
ever even talk to you I never even type
ready in my ready to go in my life
reddit is like a weird biker bar you
know that like only like regulars go and
it's Sammy oh they hate me for sure
right and then when you walk in
everybody the whole place stops even a
jukebox and they looking over you like
what are you doing in here breaking
about or sure who told you orange look
gone you like what see that's what I'm
saying like
what is like when you step onto your
comment section yes the comment section
is brutal and then sometimes what I do
is I'll do alive
like I'll premiere the episode live and
then live chat and it's like guys just
stop it you know you know I got a
moderate I'm putting people on time out
the live show you got so you gonna be on
time out okay yes I put people on time
out so it's crazy so I wanna you
probably end it in the comments right
now so you won't you I'm putting you on
time out if you're doing something funky
and that's a be respectful crying you'll
be like that's what side piece in behind
her dog in her side piece tomorrow I
don't even mind the dog but decide
anyways you know this is just a great
family person thanks for sharing your
vulnerability thanks for sharing your
your faith you know your story your
honesty I really appreciate you coming
on the podcast I've known you for so
long actually one of my first real TV
appearances was with you and I together
live at Gotham 2008 walking down the
street in Chelsea or wherever it was
they had our hotel but I do remember
walking with you down with you and I
remember feeling safe with you yeah
that's what you know what you know what
thank you because I realized it took me
so long much time later now going
through relationships and stuff like
that to realize the first thing I want
any woman to feel if I'm going I'm
dating them or just even hanging out
with a friend as I just want them to
feel safe yeah you know and it's like
that's an important thing to convey
because that's what you know that's what
y'all say I want to feel safe with you
you know so I get it I'm learning we're
all learning you know but in these
ladies out there too don't be afraid to
express yourself don't put yourself in
awkward situations that you can't
express yourself but I also understand
if you in a situation where you like I
don't think I can say anything right now
cuz this you know this is crazy so you
know kudos to you out there you know
just keep keeping you know fighting the
struggle and let's hope we can just
change the
that's right one person at a time amen
amen
oh wait yeah you got to finish with the
singer might and will end with that way
when Angela on the singing my tutor yeah
okay nobody turns it on here comes there
it is
wait that was my my church well that's
it Oh what did you why you wanna know
finish it off ladies and gentlemen
Angela Johnson
ladies gentlemen thank you for listening
to the show
oh nice movie thank you